now army in the Seven Kingdoms can match
the pride and chivalry of the Knights of
the Vale after all they were the first
true Knights in Westeros
the Knights of the Vale were originally
the Knights of handless an Eastern
nation whose people invaded Westeros
thousands of years ago from the sea the
Vale seemed to the Andals an ideal new
home they wide fertile valley isolated
from the rest of Westeros and its
kingdoms by a great mountain range the
first men who held it moreover were
sparse and divided and waded into battle
with bronze axes and armor that couldn't
match handle horses and steel but what
the first men lacked in weaponry they
made up for in ferocity finally uniting
behind king rhobar royce the first men
smashed the Andals in battle after
battle reclaiming the vale and pushing
the invaders back to the sea from whence
they'd come learning from the first men
the remaining Andals united behind a
leader of their own not a king or a lord
but a knight had been born in the Vale
and knew it as well as the first men sir
artists Aaron known as the Falcon Knight
the armies of the first man and the
Andals met beneath the giants lands to
decide the fate of the Vale so artists
had many more mounted Knights than the
first men who preferred to fight afoot
but the first men had seized the high
ground digging trenches in front of
their ranks and lining them with
sharpened stakes smeared with awful and
excrement six times the Andal knights
charged and six times the first men
threw them back but on the seventh they
fearsome and a warrior broke through the
ranks of the first men and the anvils
rushed through the gap
if king rhobar had been liza he would
have retreated and saved his army for
another day then again if he'd been wise
at all he'd never have risked his army
of foot soldiers against mounted knights
in the first place when king rhobar saw
the fog of helm of Suraj's across the
field he waged that the Andals would
break if they lost their leader and rode
hard for the Falcon Knight the singers
paint a pretty picture of the battle the
king in flashing bronze armor the night
in silvered steel but the duel lasted no
longer than a verse of the songs for
king rhobar had taken a Valyrian sword
of a dead and a lord and it sheared
through sir artists helm much like a
bird's wing through the air
of the Falken night tumbled to earth
king rhobar thought he'd won this
desperate gamble then he heard the
trumpets behind him when he turned he
saw 500 fresh and all Knights pouring
down the Giants Lance and the man at its
head was also the man at robust feat for
Sir artists unique in that age or indeed
any age esteemed cunning even more than
marshal strength and had clad one of his
knights in his spare suit of armor
leaving him to die at robas hand while
Sir artists took his best horsemen of a
goat track he knew from childhood the
charge of the and all Knights broke the
last great army of the first men who
would never again threaten the new
Knights of the Bale some of the defeated
would even join their ranks in the years
to come but many more fled to the
mountains choosing savagery over
submission
ever since the Knights of the Vale
enjoyed an exclusive position in
Westeros they could sally forth from the
Vale at will knowing that if battle went
against them they go to retreat through
the bloody gate where no army could
follow until the Dragons changed the
game
when Aegon the conquerer landed in
Westeros the Queen regent of the Vale
shut the bloody gate against the
Targaryens and masts the Knights of the
Vale behind it to lock it
but the seniya simply flew her dragon to
a balcony of the area where the boy King
was playing and gave the boy a ride
round the castle in return for his
mother's submission with the conquest no
more could the Knights of the Vale hide
behind their mountains nor they soon
discovered did they need to for
thousands of years the other kingdoms
had Ward and treated to balance each
other's might was the Vale kept to
itself
none realized what power the Vale could
have until Jon Arryn defied the Iron
Throne
refusing to surrender Ned Stark and
Robert Baratheon to the Mad King the
north the river lands and the Stormlands
couldn't have beaten the other three
kingdoms by themselves but the Knights
of the Vale rode with them
now the north is freezing the Riverlands
are burnt the Stormlands are spent
dawn is distant the westerland's are
weakened and the reach is paralyzed of
all the great armies in Westeros only
the Knights of the Vale have yet to
suffer exhaustion or defeat the bloody
gate is opening again on to Westeros and
through it passes opportunity